On the first day man was granted
A soul, and with it - Clarity. For in man, great potential was seen.
Yet on the second day upon earth was
planted
An irrevocable poison. A soul devouring Demon.
For, like the demon - man had an insatiable,
destructive appetite for souls. For power.
And so, the scourge began
As God's two most terrible creations: Man and It's Demon's
fought towards extinction.
You came for demons souls?
Or to save this land, and be remembered as a hero?
[laughs]
Hunting for demon's
That is why you came, is it not? To this accursed Boletaria?
Can't you see
you've fallen for their trap? In the dark state of our land,
Legends are all we can depend upon.
I refused to believe
that this is what father wished for our great land.
You have a heart of gold.
Don't let them take it from you!
surely you have seen for yourself..
the pain and the suffering that fills this world..?
But fight poison with poison. God is merciful,
and so, created the Old One. The Old One will feed
upon our souls..and put an end to our tragic
of existance.
But perhaps our age will see the rise of new Heroes...
Do you intend to challenge the King?
You may be a great demon hunter..
but I feel you may not be ready.
Beware the limits of your own power.